l'industrie de la pêche au québec est
actuellement composé de quelques grands
joueurs seulement qui se partagent
l'exploitation du saint laurent les
trois produits par le crabe des neiges
le homard et la crevette exporté à 80%
on y à l'exportation ses jupons peux pas
être content exportations c'est de
l'argent neuf les randos québec grâce
aux personnes qui s'opposent à ce lot
de tout ce qui est capturée au québec en
aux pêcheurs québécois lait transformé
par nos informateurs de toutes les
régions maritimes dugré on avait un peu
pour ça qu'on vend au québec jean paul
gagné représente les industriels de la
pêche au québec il a vu le marché
évoluer après presque 30 ans à la tête
de laquelle on a beaucoup amélioré la
dans l'accord du moment particulièrement
on ira du long un point où si difficile
d'un an jusque là c'est le marché
québécois sakho maintenant dernier le 5
mai de probation en augmenter les 22 35
au québec avec l'os ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts ça paraît peut-être pas
toujours mais on a une bonne
communication et les épiceries et les
grandes chaînes d'alimentation
la machine est bien huilée pour les
crustacés les plus connus le golf
déborde de petits bijoux qui peine à se
rendre jusqu'à nous a scié les plus
petits pêcheurs veulent des ventes plus
direct les consommateurs ont manifesté
un intérêt pour les produits du saint
laurent alors pourquoi c'est si
compliqué les exploiter et les garder
chez nous on a le modèle des accès sur
extra en bas les exporter il faut
structurer cette offre là en
développement justement les
infrastructures de transport de
logistique des solutions réalistes pour
ce chercheur et aller vers un modèle
plus de proximité g ça passe par des
politiques publiques par des lois des
règlements comment on peut revoir les
règles du jeu pour inciter afin inciter
entreprises à faire autrement
certainement book effectivement si c'est
compliqué on peut sur chad des comptes
sauf si le ministre andrée lamontagne
qui a le dernier mot sur toutes
nouvelles propositions de projets à
chaque fois qu'un entrepreneur fait une
demande pour avoir un permis de
transformation en plus des nombreux
documents à remplir il doit passer par
un comité d'intérêt public on est un
comité d'intérêt local qu'on appelle qui
forme et de différentes personnes qui
vise à évaluer si le ministère s'apprête
à donner un permis si le fait de donner
ce permis là sont à béja allée des
pilotes et pierre quel par ailleurs ce
territoire ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que ce comité consultant si les grands
industriels de la pêche qui peuvent donc
influencer la décision finale ou pas il
ya une poignée d'industriels qui
clairement un intérêt à maintenir ce
mode opératoire là aujourd'hui et qui
peut éventuellement faire obstacle à un
modèle différent alternatifs plus ancré
dans les territoires où on pêche
justement plusieurs espèces fait de la
plus petite pêche côtière pour établir
les principaux héros juin qui décide vos
joueurs sont consultés sur le mapaq il
décide de mettre un permis ou non
l'église avait des fleurs sur le mapaq
kamel ben je sais pas
si c'est
sûr qu'on fonctionne avec la matraque ok
faut fonctionner bientôt fonctionner
c'est ce qui a des réglementations ce
serait une réalité qui se met tout seul
moi ce que je vois succès en évolution
puis une volonté au ministère
d'accompagner avec grande ouverture
possible les projets les nouveaux
projets va falloir que les ministères
contribua à laisser de la place à ses
nouveaux joueurs là parce que 1 peuvent
changer la durabilité puis toutes les
pêcheries durables ça va passer par ces
nouveaux joyaux absolument là une
position qui n'est pas partagée par tous
faut garder la combustion est ce qu'on
va en diminuant de la moquée pour en
créer
mais j'espère qu'il ya deux boulangers
qui veulent s'établir dans une
municipalité on peut pas les empêcher de
d'ouvrir
les deux est-ce que ça va bien aller
pour les deux
bouts de l'envelope du mapaq dans ses
différents programmes elle est partagée
entre relativement petit nombre de
joueurs donc d'inclure des nouveaux
joueurs clairement ça vient divisé
l'enveloppent pour tout le monde les
discussions que j'ai pu avoir avec avec
les industriels l'ap-hp les demandes que
j'ai pu leur faire honnêtement c'est ce
que sera le sort un peu pour certains de
leur zone de confort on s'entend
là-dessus comme et j'ai jamais entendu
dire qu'il voulait pas que d'autres
personnes qui cherchaient spots et
une lampe et chevaux non mais vous avez
seulement que le processus et elle m'a
difficile pour l'atteindre c'est
seulement une minorité qui peuvent y
arriver au bout au bout du processus
donc les industriels le monde est
content il n'y a pas trop de joueurs qui
apparaît à ce marché fait que faudra
mettre coriace plus vraiment une tête de
cochon qui passe devant
[Musique]
les richesses à partager sont limitées
que
ce serait peut-être même plus
intéressant pour nous d'avoir plusieurs
petits clients à haute valeur qu'un seul
client qui achète tout à la baie on est
peut-être en train de taper la treille
l'a fait que notre rêve c'est qu'il y en
ait d'autres la décade nous aussi qui
plus est que plus personne
[Musique]